So now that we've gone over the the framework and we're closing out this
tutorial I thought it might be a nice little trick to show you how to open
multiple of these doors and how to kind of force them open should we say
through blueprint communication. So the first thing I want to show you is how
to create multiple doors that can access. So we can only reference one
door at the moment which is this door. What if I want to reference three
different doors? So let's go ahead and do that first. So I want to go into my
button blueprint. I want to get the door reference and I'm actually going to
delete this door. So I'm going to delete the door reference here. I'm going to
compile and save. Don't worry about that. We can delete that as well but yeah
we're just going to disconnect this stuff. So let's compile, save. On our door
reference you'll see that we've got the the blueprint here of the variable
and on the variable drop-down you'll see single or array. So single means
we're speaking to a single door. Array means we can speak to an array of doors.
So let's click that. Let's compile. Let's save. Let's drag this content to
the side. Let's get this variable by ctrl left mouse drag. We want to drag
off here and we want to type 4. So we want to select the first option here
for each loop. Again this is a little bit more of an advanced concept but I
think it's worthwhile digging into this and showing you exactly what can
happen here. So we want to press for each loop and we have an array element
here. So every every door that it finds in this list it will send out a
message for each of these doors. So again we want to resolve exactly like
we did last time and we want to drag into the target and we want to set it.
So if I keep this door unlocked variable you should see this. Depending on the
number of doors you'll see this prints out. So let's see. Let's compile. Let's
save. Let's go into our first person map. Now you'll see that we've got no
array elements so let's add three. Let's say this door. Let's say this
door and let's say this door. Now what you'll see is if we file let's
just save. You should see the door unlocked print out three times. So let's
say door unlocked three times. So therefore we've just unlocked three
different doors. So if I go and press ctrl at each one of these doors you'll
see them open and the default property was is locked. So that's just a really
really powerful way of creating blueprint communication for multiple
multiple actors. I hope you've got a lot from this tutorial series. We've
covered a lot of ground but hopefully it was broken down in steps so that it
allows you provides you with more confidence to move into slightly more
complex blueprint scripting and even if you only understand the communication
between a button and a door and basic blueprint communication it'll really give
you a good foundation of continuing your journey in Unreal Engine.